foreign
in Houston go Astros what's up Christian
hey John how are you partying man what
are you up to
not much just trying to find a decent
room
not partying how can I help man what's
going on
uh well my question was um
how can I control my emotions so that
they don't come out
I guess in a negative way towards my
life
tell me more what happened
so
we just
it's been a little over a month and uh
we've been living together for
over three years now and it's been hold
on what's what's been over what's been
over a little over a month
uh our mayor sorry oh you just got
married you're newlywed yeah newlywed
yep one month in
yeah a little over one month in got made
uh June 24th okay and uh got married
June 24th and you've been in for a month
you've been living together for three
years
about well we've been together for three
years but living together for about a
year okay
and um how are your emotions coming out
on your wife in a negative way
uh so it's it's
got called to my attention by her
um
a few a week and a half ago that
sometimes I'll get a little over the top
irritated and it'll come out as Miguel
or me talking in a louder fashion than I
used to I guess um
and I
I've noticed it now too that sometimes I
get
a lot of things in the back of my head
and just coming out and
a more
it's a more heavier tone than I have
used within talking to her and I
I want
I guess help on how
can I not be like that because I mean we
just we just started so I just want to
be a good husband and I appreciate that
man I appreciate that the um the first
step here is ownership
and the way you described it out of the
gate to me is
your wife noticed it not me so I'm going
to ask you and do me a favor speak
directly into the phone let's just have
like a like a manoimano text into Texan
talk here
are you yelling at your wife are you
raising your voice are you finding
yourself all pissed off for reasons that
even you're like why am I so mad
yes I yeah why how come
hi
it's hard I I'm not entirely sure
because there's
I mean I can't say I have much to
complain about it's been
but you are so so where does that come
from is it is it a sense of she should
be doing something different is it
you suddenly feel like you can't breathe
because you're married like you're a
husband just adjusting to that role and
that title which is kind of weird
um did she bait and switch you did she
date you for three years and all of a
sudden she's all different now like what
where is that coming from
no she's she's amazing uh I just
I think it's more so
I guess the chain there's we're doing a
lot of change right now like right now
I'm actually in our in my in-laws place
and now she's
um at BLC or uh NCO school because we're
both in the military
but she's away for a bit and I guess hey
stop stop real quick you've been married
for a month and you're living at your
in-laws house and you're wondering why
you're snapping at your wife are you
kidding me
I I mean we
've I've been with them a lot of times
before and uh they're great I it's just
it's been a I guess a lot of change with
we're planning a week everything between
the wedding and her going to the school
then moving it all happened
I guess in a span of maybe two two
months so
I guess maybe that combined with the
this new role might have
put a higher toll on me than everyone
how have you um
have you continued to take care of
yourself
and when I say take care of yourself
um
once a week going to meet with a group
of guys just to hang out go to shoot
shoot pool or throw darts or Bible study
whatever you're into
um or go ride skateboards do you still
exercise are you just coming home and
plopping down and watching TV a lot like
like how are you taking care of yourself
uh well I used to
as in I think it's been a month since I
went to the gym talking to the phone
talking to the phone
uh I am this is the room's not great but
uh sorry
you said for the last you said for the
last month
yeah the last month I guess I haven't
been
doing the things that I normally do like
go to the gym or
uh I mean I haven't played video games
because it's something I used to take
the stress out but
it's just
I was I mean I was focused on
I wanted to help her out because she had
to she's also now officially in her she
just
uh graduated and took her and clerks and
passed it and I guess for that time I
just
focused on trying to do like help her
out as much as I could with whatever she
needed whether it be like studying
moving or
anything just be there and
I I didn't really have a group of guys
to hang out with oh well I was there I
was kind of more just
try and do stuff by myself so so think
it's think of it this way think of it
this way what you did was pretty noble
it's pretty good I'm proud of you
um
it's common especially when you're
trying to get your footing and figure
out how to be the best husband you could
be
um
that I'm trying to think of a of a way I
can explain it
um
I'll just use the the analogy that
everybody uses that they tell you on the
plane right that when there's an
emergency and the oxygen falls out
you're supposed to put yours on first
before you start messing with your kids
and your spouse because if you suffocate
and die then everybody dies right and so
what you've done for the last month is
Honorable
you just held your breath and you made
sure that your wife had oxygen tank
after oxygen tank after oxygen tank and
my guess is if she's just now graduating
she had to do finals she had to go
through NCO stuff she had to finish up
all of her end of semester projects and
paperwork and all that stuff and you're
living with your in-laws and now you're
a husband and that just sounds like you
look down and see that ring on your
finger just feels and sounds weird right
all this is changing and weird
and in an effort to be the best guy you
could be
you made a mistake that all of us make
which is I'm gonna sacrifice myself
completely where I've got nothing left
in the tank because I'm gonna dedicate
all of my tank to her
but then you're gonna realize that you
got nothing to give
right you can't give what you don't have
and so it doesn't surprise me that you
look up and you don't have any guys to
hang out with for the last month or two
you haven't been to the gym in a month
you're probably eating take out every
night you're living with your in-laws
like there's so much stress there and it
comes out in blame it comes out in a
little sharp even if even if you have
like if your wife's sick all right I've
been married 21 years your wife's sick
and man you just your husband's sick
nobody wants him to be sick but after a
week it's like you just come out
you know it's just that feeling I'm not
mad at anybody but it's just kind of
Snappy right and you have to just be
conscious of it so
um I'm gonna give you a couple of things
that I think would really help you is
that cool
yeah please by the way
um did you have a good role model was
your old man a good role model
uh uh well my dad kind of family comes
from divorce and then my stepdad uh he's
better now but I guess growing up he
wasn't the best role model okay
um I want you to start practicing
speaking of the period at the end of
your sentence
okay okay not like a kinda I guess kind
of you know like you know man like I
don't
I want you to say I'm Christian from
Houston Texas
my stepdad was not a good guy
he's gotten better as he's got you see
the like the the Declaration the
confidence the period at the end of this
sentence not a dot dot dot not a
lipstick into the sentence okay and I
want you to say I'm gonna I'm gonna be
the best husband I can be
and what a sacrificial husband does is
he makes sure he's strong and well so
that he can go in there and be of
service
so he can help
and so I want you to make sure you're
getting back in the gym I want you to
make sure you got a group of guys you
can hang out with even if it's going to
be weird and you just invite a few guys
out to get nachos or beers or whatever
y'all do
um in town there
when do you and your wife get back into
the same zip code
uh uh at the end of the month she comes
back on the 24th okay she gets back at
the end of the month when she comes back
I want you to take her out
one just just privately just y'all two
one to celebrate this is awesome it's
amazing congratulations
number two
to tell her I want to be the best
husband you can ever dream of
and I'm kind of Flying Blind here
because I don't I didn't have that
growing up and so let's do this thing
together and here Christian if you can
get this down as a newlywed man this
will change the rest of your life okay
if you can sit with her and say
how can I love you this week
as you start your new job as we find an
apartment as we both go back to Service
as we whatever we're doing
how can I love you best this week and
here's another gift you can give her
here's what I need this week you as a
man if you can come up with the courage
and the bravery and the strength to say
out loud what you need
I need some time to go to the gym I need
some time for us to what whoa I need
some like what do you need what do you
need I want us to have a date night this
week I want to take you out on a date
we make a budget with me like what are
these things that you need I think
that'd be incredible and we're just
gonna do this on a weekly by weekly
basis and if you guys can begin to
practice having this meeting on a weekly
basis
it will change your marriage forever
last homework assignment my brother is
you have to find one or two men who've
been married a long time and that you
look up to and ask them hey guys can I
take you out to coffee can I take you
out for a drink I want to learn the
secrets
I'm a new husband I'm figuring this out
live and I want to learn how to do this
well can I pick your brain
and man I I would be so honored if
somebody asked me that like hey can I go
learn about how to do this I think that
would be fantastic man but it's your job
to reach out and find some good mentors
some good coaches think of it this way
um you just got a job in the NBA
as a professional basketball player but
you've never seen a game of basketball
played well you've never seen it you've
never seen Michael Jordan play you've
never seen Hakeem Olajuwon the greatest
of all time play you've never seen
anybody play
how in the world can you play basketball
if you've never seen it done same with
being a husband if you did not have a
good picture of that growing up you
cannot just make it up out of thin air
or off Tick Tock videos
you got to get some real men in your
life that you sit down with on some sort
of regular basis maybe once a month once
every six months maybe just once at one
one at a time that's all the time I got
I'm gonna pick your brain I'm gonna
learn from you I wanna I wanna Implement
some things and come back to you dude
that'd be fantastic so hang on the line
here's my uh my wedding gift you I'm
gonna give you a couple of things
number one I'm gonna give you a copy of
both on your past change your future and
building a non-anxious life my two books
I'm gonna hook you guys up for free I
want you to read them together it's
going to talk about what happened when
y'all are kids and it's going to cast a
vision into the future for your marriage
the second thing I'm going to give you
is Financial Peace University and a year
subscription to every dollar okay a year
subscription this is a budgeting app and
this sounds like I don't need budgeting
app listen
this is simply a tool for couples to use
to bring themselves to the table
together once a week
and people think like budgeting
budgeting business about money no no
it's way more about that because if you
sit down and do a budget then you have
to talk about priorities you should talk
about needs you have to talk about what
do you want you have to talk about I
don't like this
you have to have all those messy
conversations that's why budgeting sucks
it's hard because it's not just about
dollars and cents it's about
self-control and discipline and
priorities
so I'm going to send that to you it
links up to your bank it's almost need
the premium one for a year man it seems
it syncs up to your bank that's my
wedding gift to you and Financial Peace
just gonna give you guys a road map to
getting together with money which again
man if couples will get together with
money it forces them to have some hard
conversations and it gets them on the
same page with almost everything
I'm proud of you man I'm proud of you
Christian
last thing I'll say
never ever yell at your wife
make that a red letter line for you
I will not yell at my wife I'll hang up
the phone I'll walk away I'll go for a
walk I will not yell at my wife
make that a a a a personhood it's your
identity